لا زالت توتر سيد المشهد في ايران 40 يوما
تمضي على وفاه مهسه امينه ومعها احتجاجات
لم تتوقف في البلاد ماتت الشابه الايرانيه
بعد توقيفها لانتهاكها المفترض لقواعد
اللباس الصارمه في الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
نظم المظاهرات عدد من الطالبه الايرانيين
في بعض الجامعات من بينها جامعه بهيشتى
اضافه الى جامعه خوجا نصير توصيل
التكنولوجيا في طهران وهذا رغم القمع الذي
يتعرض له المحتجون مع تزايد التوتر في
البلاد بحسب منظمات حقوقيه في جامعه جمران
في الاهواز بمحافظه خرزستان تردد الطلبه
شعارات كثيره لعل ابرزها قد يموت الطالب
لكنه لن يقبل الاذلال يتحدون كما يبدو
السلطات الامنيه التي تمنع المظاهرات
وتفرقها بالقوه تاتي التظاهرات الجديده
بعد اتهام ناشطين عناصر امن بيتلميذات في
مدرسه الشهيد الصدر المهنيه للبنات في
مقاله وزاره التعليم ان خلافا وقع بين
تلميذات واهالهن وموظفي المدرسه هذا
سطرابات داميه محافظه كردستان وهي مسقط
راس اميني وكذلك زهدان في اقصى جنوب شرق
ايران وافادت وكاله تسنيم الايرانيه ان
مسلحين مشغولين قتلوا عناصر من الحرس
الثوري في المحافظه الايرانيه تعلن السلطه
القضائيه توجيها الاتهام الى 300 شخص على
خلفيه الاحتجاجات التي اعقبت وفاه امين
كما اكدت اعتقال ايرانيين واجانب في قضيه
الجواسيس الفرنسيين بحسب طهران تؤكد ان
المعتقلين الجدد متهمون بالتواطئ والتامر
بهدف الاضرار بالامن القومي